what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
player stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion I'm
Paul and I know how to make headlines
sure limit theorem at Manchester care
knowing Gallagher I'm so good I'm in the
MLS and they still for being this intro
everybody knows I'm at the same level of
Messi and Ronaldo why is everybody
laughing absolutely Oh
first the World Cup now this I don't get
to go to anything fun okay for once the
World Cup suck this year secondly this
party is for dummkopf Sark oh please
they have a chocolate fountain just like
home as your captain
I say nein he has his chocolate fountain
in his home so every year by on this
Rose is parties they act like they are
just cool fun guys but really the
hosting is just a ploy to poach the best
young players from the other Bundesliga
teams Marco's have a bit sensitive about
this because he's was many Dortmund
friends over the years
eleven douse key almost and of course me
what can I say I was young and I needed
to pet my cherry
[Music]
hey haven't you guys seen my lederhosen
I can find them oh wow hey yuppie puppy
[Music]
wow there's like twice as many people at
this party as a as an Oppenheimer yeah I
just saw someone I didn't know
hey first coach oh come on let me throw
my whole team is in there sorry I have
to see ID for anyone who looks 16 or
younger is there oh hi Jules the
American kid for Dalton bribe Chris
Christian yeah oh cool I'm Jerome this
is Thomas so please you can just call me
one daughter one daughter is a nickname
I gave to myself there's no vert in
English for it but it sort of means of
space interpreter it's very cool
actually do you see him anywhere Naha a
device first breakfast sausage station
after breakfast time
horrid zona sorry is let's go so yeah I
spend new bars the flying dutchman we're
having an after-party sour you should
come we don't go to die boss what's like
your favorite thing about the Bundesliga
I mean if I'm being honest I don't
really consider us as if we're in this
Liga why we're sort of like PSG and
League on our Justin Timberlake or in
C's let's just say it's the Bundesliga
is bare watch because it's only 20 years
old you Bavarian crepes swing vote are
you okay no I'm into space just please
give me some space to interpret you
can't be talking to them so I'll just
you're not my dad you're just bitter
because they never won
how dare you fine you want him 70
million euros it is yours fit but for
him
[Laughter]
[Music]